and finally new role when it comes to
how you run for office there has to be a
middle ground between body-slamming
reporters and whatever it is the
Democrats doing you may have seen last
week that on the eve of a special
election for the House seat in Montana a
ridiculous bald bastard named Greg John
forté running for the Republicans
physically assaulted a reporter for
asking a question about health care how
are you guys the last time you did the
same thing and then he won the election
by seven points naturally Democrats were
ecstatic because Trump won the state by
twenty so we beat the spread we beat the
spread you know we keep having these
special elections where Democrats keep
almost winning and by that I mean losing
since 2009 Democrats have lost over 800
seats in state legislatures they don't
control a single chamber in the south
they only have 16 governors even
RadioShack is like how are you guys
still in business
[Laughter]
after congressman elect John forté was
charged with assault
reporters approached his Democratic
opponent who said nothing he declined to
comment and here's the radio ad the
fearsome Democrats made after the
assault if Gregg Jeanne Forte could be
sentenced to jail should he really be
elected to Congress Oh burn yes there's
nothing that moves voters in Butte
Montana like Socratic irony you know the
Democrats symbolism you'll because
that's the other animal that just stands
there when you beat it in the summer of
2016
President Obama knew the Russian
meddling was a hundred percent targeted
to elect Trump and chose not to say
anything he didn't use it because he was
afraid of how it would look
Republicans never care how things look
did Mitch McConnell care how it looked
when he stole Obama's Supreme Court pick
no he did it for the same reason a dog
licks his balls cuz he can
for decades Republicans accused
Democrats of being soft on Russia now we
got a Republican president who wasn't
just soft on Russia he's totally hard
for it everyone he knows has had secret
meetings with the Russians and lied
about it including the National Security
Advisor the Attorney General and the
royal son-in-law they hijacked the
election and he invites them into the
Oval Office gives them secret Intel
admits to obstruction of justice on TV
but when asked about impeachment Nancy
Pelosi says what are the facts that you
that you would make a case on what are
the rules that he may have violated if
you don't have that case you're just
participating in more hearsay yo look
below you it says Trump shared
classified information with the Russian
Foreign Minister
would Republicans be so reserving of
judgment even after Hillary was
exonerated they were chanting lock her
up
not wait and see it's one thing to bring
a knife to a gunfight the Democrats are
bringing a covered dish Adam Schiff says
no one ought to rush to embrace the most
extraordinary remedy that removes the
president and Eric's wall well concurs
he says we need to assemble all the
facts facts have you listened to this
administration facts don't count anymore
they're disdained they're pariahs
they're Charlie Sheen's dick
[Applause]
[Music]
when they go low we go high is a great
applause line but as a tactic what
country do you think you're living in
now wake up and smell the [ __ ]
because it turns out when they go low
they get reelected
they take the Congress the Supreme Court
the presidency from now on the
democratic motto should be when they go
low we kick them in the nuts Democrats
have to start actually winning elections
I want some candidates on my team who
can at least metaphorically
bodyslam the Republicans they put a
journalist in the hospital we put a
lobbyist in the mall last year
Republican Congressman Michael McCaul
said about Hillary's infamous private
server he said in my opinion quite
frankly it's treason see they're not
afraid to say to T word about nothing
her private server was treason no Trump
being Putin's private server that's
treason
[Applause]